dans ce hameau de montsauche chantal et
jean paul ont rejoint leur maison la
semaine dernière cette année la
perspective de l'épidémie les a poussés
à quitter la région parisienne et leurs
familles avec un peu d'avancé pour
protéger tout le monde on a préféré
venir ici un petit peu plus tôt résidant
ici depuis 16 ans il était naturel pour
eux de venir dans le morvan
pourtant le regard de quelques habitants
a changé bon on va dire est ce que vous
nous amenez la maladie la maladie on n'a
pas parlé d'autre chose mais bon on est
revenu à mon qu'on peut la mener
mais notre but premier c'est pas ça mais
on peut la mener bien sûr que les
meneurs mais là d'où on vient bon je
sais que le risque quasiment nul
car dans le village l'arrivée de
résidences secondaires en période de
confinement suscite des réactions
variées cinq étapes et au monde pourquoi
ça parce qu'on a peur qu'il ya qui nous
apporte le virus des paris on est quand
même retiré un peu donc beaucoup de
médecins beaucoup de pas grand chose
quoi les virus circulent il faut pas
être paniqué ç'a déjà existé si on passe
à travers tant mieux la peur de voir
arriver le coc vie de 19 dans des
endroits où aucun cas n'a encore été
signalé et d'un changement imprévu des
habitudes dans les commerces notamment
en brassant ils se mettent eux en
sécurité mais est ce qu'ils pensent à
nos personnes âgées je suis pas sûr que
oui mais après la gnagna j'achète
beaucoup plus donc nous on a augmenté
nos commandes
je les comprends tout à fait mais après
il faut aussi respecter les règles que
le gouvernement impose dont les environs
certaines maisons se sont rouvertes ces
derniers jours et il a parfois fallu
rappeler aux nouveaux arrivants que le
confinement n'étaient pas des vacances
quand il est arrivé le premier jury
viennent presque 20 degrés alors c'est
s'apprêtait à aller se promener au bord
du lac où il ya eu des contrôles il ya
eu des rappels ça s'est fait dans le bon
ordre et maintenant c'est l'inspecteur
les comportements se sont adaptés au
bord du lac des settons pas un promeneur
à l'horizon résidence secondaire ou à
l'année maintenant tous sont soumis aux
mêmes consignes rester chez eux